Property 2 says that each level must be consistent. In other words,
that Operations preserve invariance.
We will use the term Valid to denote Operations with these properties. That is,
we wanted to be to, want to ensure that all our operations are valid.
Using the rotations we just introduced, we can express Property 2 precisely by
saying that for each operation. The following must hold. Well, first off, that
we have an abstract invariant over state s', and we have the preconditions for
s, and we have the postconditions for s. If we have all three of those things,
then the invariant, the abstract invariant must hold on the state afterwards.
Remember that that's the state s' with an apostrophe on it.
You have, invariant true before on the state.
You have the pre-conditions all set so the operation can run.
If the operation runs and leaves the post conditions the way we expect. And
it better be the case that the invariants are true on the state resulting.
Now that said for the model that we've done so far there is no invariance.
Okay, but we're going to need this later when we get to the refinement so
I thought I'd introduce it now.